not all filmmakers like their movies to
have simple endings some leaves are last
seen ambiguous to keep audiences
thinking but sometimes that plan
backfires resulting in endings that are
just plain confusing
beware of spoilers inception Christopher
Nolan 2010 film left audiences mind
spinning as much as the top in the final
shot just when it looks like the top is
about to spin out and tumble the screen
cuts to black the final shot shows Dom
called reuniting with his kids well we
never know if it's really happening or
if it's a dream fans debated the scene
endlessly for years after Inception came
out but according to Nolan the non
ending is actually kind of the whole
point
in 2015 the director gave the
commencement speech at Princeton
University and told the grads to chase
their reality he used the ending of
Inception as an example saying Kolbert
was off with his kids he was in his own
subjective reality he didn't really care
anymore and that makes a state perhaps
all levels of reality a valid the camera
moves over the spinning top just before
it appears to be wobbling it was cut to
black in short
the ending of the movie is up to us and
were right either way the Dark Knight
Rises the ending to Nolan's Dark Knight
trilogy isn't quite as Vegas inception
but it still left viewers debating after
the credits started rolling after flying
a nuclear bomb out of Gotham City Batman
escapes the blast off screen we know
this because later while Alfred is in
Florence he sees Bruce Wayne sitting at
a table enjoying a meal with ex Catwoman
Selina Kyle some fence obscure eyes that
this is all a dream that Batman actually
died in the explosion and that Alfred
simply imagined seeing his friend taking
in the Italian sunshine but that that
Bologna before the movies end we learn
along with Lucius Fox that Wayne fixed
that that planes autopilot six months
before the final showdown in Gotham
that's all the exposition necessary for
viewers know that Batman jumped out
while the plane flies the bomb toward
the bay when Alfred sees Wayne in
Florence it's exactly how Alfred
describes it earlier in the film
but that's
not a dream it's just the best way for
Twain to show our brick he's alive
moreover Selina Kyle is there wearing
Wayne's mother's necklace which she
steals at the beginning of the movie
Alfred doesn't know she and Wayne of the
common item and he'd already quit
working for Bruce before Batman and
Catwoman teamed up to save Gotham City
as if all that isn't enough
Christian Bale himself thinks that Bruce
is alive by the end of the movie he
explains during an interview while
promoting Exodus gods and kings
he was just content with me being alive
and left because that was always the
life that he wanted for him and I find
it very interesting and with most films
I tend to always say it's what the
audience thinks it is my personal
opinion is snow was not a drink but that
was for real and he was just delighted
that finally he had freed himself from
the the privilege but ultimately the
burden of being Bruce Wayne
none of this matters anyway that Fleck
is the wave of the future but let's
shift our gaze towards the ghost of
Batman's past birdman alejandro g in uri
toes film about a washed-up actor trying
to make a comeback on broadway as the
kind of weird ending that puts inception
to shame throughout the film riggan
Thomson is shown as having superpowers
only to have the letter be explained as
being all in his head in the final scene
Reagan's daughter Sam enters its
hospital room to find his bed empty and
the window open sirens and voices can be
heard coming from the street for life
initially Sam looks down but she slowly
turns her head up to the sky and she
smiles some might think this means
riggan actually does have powers and has
flown away but probably not what really
seems to have happened is that riggan is
successfully committed suicide which he
failed to do on the previous day Sam for
her part seems to start hallucinating
just like a dad the fact that she has
bird tattoos on her arm and that a
father played a superhero with bird
based powers suggests the strong
connection between the two Sam seems to
leave the real world to enter a fantasy
where father is still alive soaring
above the clouds the film is subtitled
the unexpected virtue of ignorance after
all here
chooses to ignore reality one of
Birdman's for screenwriters Alexander
Janelle Harris jr. hinted during an
interview with HuffPost life that the
key to the understanding of the ending
lives within Sam's relationship with a
father I think when we found the
relationship with the daughter we
started to understand what Riggins story
was once she got down
Emma's big monologue in the basement we
started to understand the relationship
and what it was we're not going to sit
around and explain the ending Vanilla
Sky instead of a feel-good romance or a
fun coming-of-age story viewers of
Vanilla Sky got a moody elliptical
remake of a hit Spanish film a feckless
playboy suffers near death and
disfigurement after a relationship with
his new girlfriend plunges his acts into
homicidal obsession but once his face is
surgically restored his life really
starts to go haywire viewers are told
that much of what they've seen is a
lucid dream
in Cruzes brain which has been held in a
cryogenic stasis for more than a hundred
years the more troubling elements of the
narrative are apparently the result of a
glitch he's given the choice to either
reboot the dream or exit it once and for
all by jumping off a building and being
brought back to life he jumps and the
last shot is of the protagonist opening
his eyes starting his life over again
director Cameron Crowe said that the
correct answer to understanding the
movie might just be accepting what you
see on screen as the actual events of
the story according to his comments on
the DVDs commentary track crew seemed to
lean in that direction while talking
with film School Rejects
about the film's unused alternate ending
as well saying you want people to
understand what you're going for so the
question is looking at both endings did
the pendulum swing too much in the
direction of us explaining stuff I think
it did the original ending was more
open-ended a little less explained but
and think at the end of this Coen
brothers flick tortured writer Barton
think wanders onto a beach where he
meets a woman resembling the picture
decorating his space depressing hotel
room shortly after they made the movie
abruptly ends potentially leaving some
viewers scratching their heads what's it
mean here's one way to look at it the
represents the idea of Hollywood it's a
place of fantasy beaches and beautiful
women meanwhile throughout the entire
film think is subjected to the reality
of Hollywood he's had his scripts torn
apart by an executive he found out his
hero writer WP Mayhew is a washed-up
alcoholic and that may use wife writes
his novels for him and he fled from both
a burning hotel and a shotgun wielding
maniac you'd think that finally finding
the woman on the beach would mean that
think is at the end of his trials having
reached his reward and a place where he
feels safe but in fact he's learned the
truth about the dangerous world in which
he now exists Joe Cohen explained in a
1991 interview some people have
suggested that the whole second part of
the film is nothing but a nightmare but
it was never our intention to in any
literal sense depict some bad dream and
yet it is true that we were aiming for a
logic of the irrational we wanted the
film's atmosphere to reflect the
psychological state of the protagonist
that wouldn't be the last time the
ending of a Coen Brothers movie left
audiences debating after leaving the
theater No Country for Old Men at the
end of his blood-soaked near Western
sheriff Edie Tom Bell tells his wife
about two dreams he has about his father
in the first dream he loses some money
his father gave him in the second dream
Bell sees his father holding a torch
riding ahead into the darkness of a
snowy mountain pass surely before Bell
tells the stories of his dreams he tells
his wife that his father died young that
in a sense his father will always be a
younger man more importantly throughout
the movie Belle Ponder's the violent in
the area where he's sheriff and since
she's close to a retirement he wonders
whether he's too old for the world the
title of the movie is No Country for Old
Men and Belle is one of them it's become
too violent too quickly for someone of
his age and he can no longer cope the
world needs someone younger like his
father to light the way in ever-growing
darkness around it exactly like the
second green Belle describes as for the
first ring maybe Belle just needs a new
wallet Mulholland Drive David Lynch fans
don't Watchers work they're
straightforward now
but even in the context of between
daringly weird filmography 2001 s
Mulholland Drive is tough to figure out
Lynch himself has steadfastly refused to
help untangle the movie which moves in
jittery circles around an actress a
mysterious woman and a film director all
of whom are mixed up in a dreamlike and
frequently nonsensical series of events
ultimately the film's ending is every
bit as open to interpretation as the
rest of the film
and although viewers are welcome to
delve into the many theories attempting
to explain what Lynch might have meant
the best explanation was arguably posed
by the late film critic Roger Ebert
according to him the movie is hypnotic
we're drawn along as if one thing leads
to another but nothing leads anywhere
and that's even before the characters
start to fracture and recombined like
flesh cord in a kaleidoscope there is no
explanation there may not even be a
mystery so what's the explanation uh
pretty much whatever you want you're
welcome
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all these other cool
stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]